you are a I don't want to embarrass you
but you're a very good-looking man and
yet I've noticed
wow that's embarrassed right there oh I
can't believe you thought that oh come
on
but you know what you seem to like
playing characters that are not
attractive yeah is that because I kind
of feel sorry for those who are ugly I
want to feel even if it's only for a
second how it feels like drama bone yeah
like how does it feel to be that when
you think I'm kidding but I'm not no
let's talk about your look in in in
loving Pablo we have it we have their
slick way did you hear that a woman
scream there was an audible scream let's
put that up there you look absolutely
wait I mean what's above the look the
hair for all the hair on the hair is let
me rephrase this it's very hard I try
for the collar on I've been here you
been coming to this show for nothing
it's hard can you go back to that to the
picture yeah okay you know that they on
that picture
yeah no you can get back at me now look
at me do you know how hard is for me to
look at you and see that thing moving
[Laughter]
beautiful get big you want me to wear
this yeah this is a Pablo Escobar will
Escobar I don't know where's the monkey
we're on Halloween now all right here we
go I'll put on a pub Louis it's just
gonna make you more comfortable
now what here
[Applause]
you are great you're great but this is
it look like Super Mario you know and we
all know who he hangs out with who the
cartoons you missed the first part of
the show but you'll pick it up later on
yeah
you